[Music]
what we are witnessing here is the
return of tightness
[Music]
how many these things are there 17 and
captain that musta
[Music]
mother Rodin Ghidorah
they're moving like a pack they're
hunting they all respond directly to an
alpha
we stop this Ghidorah we stop them all
is there another creature that might
stand a chance against
[Music]
our planet will perish
so a week
[Applause]
less we set Godzilla free
oh yeah sure let's bring him in for a
beer no this time we join the fight
run
mrs. Godzilla's well we just live in it
damn right
go then Ghidorah oh my
they're everywhere nice comforting
our planet will perish
and so a week
unless me self cause I'm afraid
this time we join him
that's messed up get things on our side
[Music]
here we go
this is Godzilla's world you just live
in it damn right
[Music]
our world is changing the mass
extinction we feared has already begun
and we are the cause we are the
infection
[Music]
but like all living organisms the earth
unleashed a fever to fight this
infection its original and rightful
rulers the Titans for thousands of years
these creatures have remained in hiding
around the world and unless all the
Titans are found our planet will perish
and so will we
they are the only guarantee that life
will carry on
[Music]
you are out of your goddamn minds I am
sorry but this is the only way
[Applause]
your monster
[Music]
long live the king
[Music]
and what's with the light show it's an
intimidation display Cazares very
intimidated
we open Pandora's box and there's no
closing it now
[Music]
the king
Godzilla hello
is anyone there
I'm trying to reach
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
senators we believe that these Titans
are just the tip of the iceberg which of
these Titans are here to protect us and
[Music]
which of these Titans are here to
threaten us
so you'd want to make Godzilla our pet
no we would be his you're sure he's
gonna be okay
they're everywhere battling for
dominance
arrival alpha to Godzilla you gotta be
kidding
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the time has come
you